hey welcome to other technology Tuesday
today i'm going to be reviewing a
website from one of my newsletter
readers Gaurav he asked me to check out
this website taka tak foods co uk so I'm
going to give him my thoughts and
hopefully help him improve so this is
the website when I load it and it's taka
taka foods co uk and the first thing I
see is you know what I like the clean
layout I like the clean design the
template that's awesome what I want you
to do when I come to your website is
give me a clear understanding of the
values that you stand for okay so you
have this here for busy mobile people
whose time is at a premium but desire
freshly prepared food cooked in a homely
style okay first of all it's a little
bit hard to read you know the right on
the block it's hard to you're forcing my
honor to actually read this but there's
a lot of different things you're talking
about here so mobile people times at a
premium freshly prepared food homely
style a lot of different messaging I
like how clean the website is a simple
page you have an order and catering but
it's not making me feel anything yet I
come here universe the universe can take
a while to deliver we don't so you're
emphasizing the service and then choose
some a wide variety offered by our menus
spoilt for choice I'm not sure spoilt
it's actually a word maybe that maybe it
isn't in London or maybe I am just
ignorant but I would think it's spoiled
anyway again hard to read right like
you're forcing me to read this the font
is is not great the coloring could be
better but it's it looks nice but it's
not memorable that's the problem so what
I need you to do is find your one word
find the one word that defines who you
are as a person who defines your
business so maybe after looking all this
it's something like service maybe you
really believe when your core that
service is important service to your
customer service to your family service
to your country service I'm just taking
as an example if that's your word then
across everything should be serviced I
should
you'll service if I go to let's look at
your facebook oops let's look at your
facebook or kind of click on the
facebook okay let's look at your twitter
twitter is not working okay well i can't
check these out so what I fix that but
regardless whenever I go to any of your
marketing materials that should come out
so number one is find your one word
number two is and make me feel your
business make me feel it so I'll come to
your site and it should embody service
and if I love service I should be head
over heels I gotta call this company up
right away cuz now yeah you kind of look
like everybody else right does anybody
who does this anybody who who's a
caterer is going to say the same thing
right they all say the same thing you
get lots of selection you know it's
fresh food it's prepared in a homeless
tile everybody says the exact same thing
so how are you different that's the
problem I can't separate you from every
other caterer out there but if i come to
your site and you show me service you
make me feel service or whatever your
keyword is your one word now you're
standing out because you make me feel
something and that's what i want i want
to hit 10 different catering websites
and when i land on your as i say wow and
I feel something important and that
should be across all your marketing if I
click on your twitter or facebook i'm
assuming these things actually have
pages let's see if i cover over this it
says twitter.com slash taka taka foot
let me try that i think i saw your
twitter account so I load it up so
there's no tweets okay so we have no
tweets you know you don't to be linking
to this here with with nothing no
content we've seen your catering company
providing lunch meals the clients in the
Canary Wharf area we deal with
specialized non veg and veg Indian
delicacies this is so boring this is so
boring and again now it's another
message right before you're talking
about speedy delivery home cook meals
for busy people that's freshly made and
now you're talking about vegetarian
non-vegetarian Canary Wharf it's it's so
many things to remember
that I don't remember anything so make
it easy for me okay I want to feel your
business as soon as I hit your website
and as soon as I hit any piece of
content that you put out I want to feel
something and the third thing is we want
to apply this to everything that you do
so number one is find your one word
number to make me feel your business and
three apply to everything that you do so
service if that's your word you need to
apply to everything right it's not just
your marketing it's when I call you up
do I get good service you know when
somebody drops off the food do I feel
like they really service me are again or
whatever your one word is you need to
apply it but you need to live and
breathe your one word and it should be
important to you because this is who you
are when you find that one word it does
a couple of things one that makes it
easier to make decisions right if your
word of service then it's easy to make a
decision on you know who to hire what
products to introduce what markets to go
into because it all comes down the
service if you are bringing on somebody
who you know maybe you know may show up
on time and you know may be able to do
the job really well but doesn't like
providing great service this should be a
no-brainer right that guy is not a fit
for you so makes decisions easier it
also makes it easier for you to stay
motivated right like if you really
believe the world needs better service
and you're on a mission to make the
world better in that way in your own
small way it makes it easier to get up
and stay motivated if you're just
getting up trying to make a few extra
dollars it's going to be hard to stay
motivated to be hard to keep going you
have to feel like you're doing something
important that's what we crave as
peoples to do something important and
three and most important and most
relevant to your question is it makes it
easy for people to talk about you what
am I going to say about you you've given
me like eight different messages here I
don't remember any of them but if you
give me one simple message that embodies
everything that you do in a value that
you believe to your core and that moves
people then it makes it easy for me to
talk about you so you got to go to
attack attack foods these guys get
service that's easy to say that's easy
to spread
the word so you're giving your customers
a tool you're arming them to go out and
spread the word for you because you've
made it easy for them to do it right now
I wouldn't know what to say so you've
got a great you know design but if you
can follow those strategies number one
find your one word number to make people
feel your business and number three
apply to everything that you do you have
a lot more success believe for those of
you watching you liked this video you
can subscribe to the channel to see more
just like this thank you so much and
I'll see you soon